房廠關鍵字,帶你掌握新趨勢。
大家好,歡迎收看今天的節目,我是Amy。
不知道大家有沒有發現,
央行從2024年9月19日開始的第七波信用管制已經要滿兩年了。
而且央行也鬆口說不會再有更嚴格的房貸管制政策。
那究竟未來房市會怎麼轉變呢?
為什麼過了這兩年的房市冷靜期,價格還是這麼硬啊?
我們現在到底能不能購買呢?
今天就為大家邀請到了房產專家
永慶房屋業管部的協理陳四傑
為我們帶來的詳細的數據分析
要來告訴我們房市的真實內幕喔!
協理你好
主持人好
各位觀眾朋友大家好
協理其實我們從剛剛講到的
第七波的信用管制
還有房貸的緊縮的政策
其實都是政府為了要來打擊這些炒作
還有抑制過熱的房市
但是實際上過了這兩年
這個房市到底有沒有什麼樣的變化了呢
哇 好啦 Amy很厲害
我想其實剛剛已經很精準的提到
這一次央行的政策目的
我想其實央行祭出這些管制的措施
最主要的是要抑制給多屋主
從這個貸款乘數的部分來限制
但是它同時也要照顧
有些是自用的換屋需求
所以它也適度的開放了
這是針對第二戶以上的房貸乘數的一個上限
能夠放鬆對這個換屋主的貸款限制
那最近又推出了最新的
這個清安3.0的優惠貸款
它主要是要優先支持
只是目前沒有房的首購主
然後讓這個房屋買賣
能夠迴歸到自住的一個需求
好我們可以從最近幾年的
這個建物買賣移轉動數
來發現市場確實跟之前比起來
已經明顯的降溫了
那六都的都會區
在2025年的上半年的買賣移轉動數
年減幅達到26%
那2026上半年
也還有在相對微降了大概3%
所以這個減幅已經有大幅的收斂
所以從這一年半看來
整體的房屋市場
應該整體區域比較穩定的一個現象
好 但是賢伶我還是想要再請教
因為你剛剛的這個圖表裡面
我們雖然說看到這個買賣移轉動數
是有往下滑
然後你也說到這個會區域穩定
但是我們身邊很多的朋友
都開始在看房子
實際上到這個房市這樣進去看
沒有感覺穩定
對 到底這個買賣移轉動數
它這個主成分是什麼呢
那其實在整個不動產的買賣移轉動數裡面
它裡麵包含了幾個成分
第一個是成屋的交易件數
那另外也包含了預售屋完工後的交屋
所以預售屋也在裡面
那另外還有就是一般民眾自己會有一些自售
自己買自己賣的這樣的件數
整個都包含在這個裡面
所以你很難直接從數字的反應就看出
實際現在成屋市場的買氣
那所以也讓這個成屋市場的市況
跟現階段的這個建物買賣一轉動數的數字
看起來會有些脫鉤
那我們這邊用永晉內部的這個指標數據來看
那其實在今年2026的第二季的整個房市
已經有出現明顯回溫的一個現象
我們來看這張表
我們排除掉今年農曆年
我們的這個因為有年假的因素
我們以1月份完整的整個月來當作基準
我們把1月跟5月還有6月的房屋的看屋諮詢量
來做一個比較
其實已經有增加超過一成以上了
分別是12.1%跟10.4%
而且不止在看護人變多
我們再看5月跟6月的實際的成交量
也跟1月比較分別增加了15.4%跟7%
這數字都說明了
從整個房屋不止諮詢量的提升
其實從後端的成交也明顯有一些增長
也顯示這幾個月的房屋的買氣
其實已經有明顯的提升
非常感謝協理帶來
在市場上這麼及時的一手的資訊
看來今年的買氣確實是有在回升
Amy說的沒錯
那我們這邊也準備了
永慶房產集團內部的成交數據
來跟觀眾朋友做分享
我們看從今年的第二季開始
那整個交易的量成長是相對有感
我們把4月的成交年增是17%
那5月的年增是23%
那6月也維持年增有16%的表現
所以整體跟去年比較起來
其實相對是已經明顯的成長
那如果接下來的整體的經濟
能夠維持穩健的成長
而且我們出口一樣維持現在的這個暢望
另外是臺股繼續維持在這個高檔
我們推估在2026年的
第三季的房市的交易量
應該還是有小增的機會
所以整體這樣來看的話
我們現在的城屋市場
是有逐漸在回溫
然後成交量也是彈升
那預售屋的市場
現在表現又是如何呢
好我們就從預售屋的
實價登錄的數據來看
我想整體預售屋在這兩年買氣
確實有變得比較冷清
那我們也分析統計了
今年一到六月的預售屋的實價登錄
我們看到每個月平均
大概只有三千件左右的一個成交
這樣子的話這兩年預售屋
它的交易量真的是會很不樂觀的
對嗎
好我想回歸到這次政策的本質
它就是要降低房地產的投機炒作
所以第一個就是投機客已經
大幅度的退出這個預售的市場
第二個也因為政策的關係
有些自助的買方心態也會轉為比較觀望
那所以預售市場的這個買氣
確實就因此受到了影響
那也因為整個去化速度變慢
所以整個預售屋在市場的這個代售庫存
是持續的一個增加
那我們準備一張表跟觀眾朋友來分享
我們從數據來看
全臺在2023年以前
推出的預售屋的建案銷售率
都有突破八成
我想各都大概都落在這個地方
那2024年的第七波信用管制之後
我們看得到買氣大幅的減少
那預售建案的銷售率也掉到五成
2025年以後的預售
這個建案的銷售率更只剩下兩成多
那我們來細看七大都會區的銷售狀況
除了雙北市因為這個自住的需求相對比較強勁
那加上供給的量也比較少
所以還勉強維持有在四成的這個銷售率
那其他我們看從桃園以南
這兩年的銷售率平均都不到兩成
這個數字真的非常的驚人
代表說很多的預售屋建案開出來
可能賣不到兩成
這個買氣就凍結了
而且大家不敢買預售的原因
應該就是價格開了實在太高了
已經高不可攀了
而且也聽說就是這個雙北市場的
這個城屋和預售屋
它的這個價差已經足足可以
快要買一臺國產汽車了
到底為什麼這個價差會這麼大
好我們這邊也準備了
臺北市今年的預售屋平均單價
來跟觀眾朋友分享
我們看到2026一到四月的預售屋
平均單價是落在130萬
那我們看另外一條線是針對城屋
城屋的大樓大概只有82萬
這一來一回單價就差了48萬
我想價差幅度逼近到了六成
如果把它轉換成購屋的總價
我們用30坪的房屋來做計算
30乘以這個48
價差就相近1500萬
我想這樣的價差
對購屋主來講確實是不小的一個負擔
這個48萬就是不知道怎麼來的
真的很驚人
好那我們再來看一看這個新北市好不好
我們看一下這個新北市的價差
它的差距有沒有比較縮小了一點
好來我們來看新北市的這張表
一樣我們在今年一到四月
新北市的預售屋平均單價落到72萬
那成屋的大樓是46萬
一樣來回價差的有26萬
這個幅度跟臺北市比起來
差一點點 但是其實也已經逼近了六整的價差
好 那我想我們觀眾應該有看到我們剛才那兩張的表格
那這個預售屋跟中古屋的價差真的是逐年在增加擴大
那City可以幫我們來分析一下
到底這兩條線為什麼會價差這麼的巨大呢
好 沒有問題
我想建商他在推預售屋有幾個考量點
我想第一個 他在定價的時候就是土地成本
還有營建成本 再來就是人工成本
當然另外它最重要
它的合理的一個利潤
那現在從土地建材
跟人工成本值越來越高
那建商要能夠主動讓利
我想這個狀況會比較少
那所以它整個整體的價格彈性
相對就比較小
所以預售的價格
它不容易往下走
那我們反觀
成屋市場最大的優質是什麼
因為每個房屋出售的業主都不同
動機也不同
那所以它的價格彈性比較大
也能夠比較快速反映
現階段市場的一個變化
那回到消費者買房的這個角度來看
成屋它能夠買到的坪數
會比預售屋買到的坪數來得大
因為單價的差異
那所以以上這些條件
也讓近期的成屋市場
會比預售屋市場的這個表現來得穩定
對 沒錯
按照現在當前市場這樣的風向
就是買方那個需求
換成是我的話
我也會選擇這種看得到又摸得到
然後價格又相對親民的這個成屋
我再來還是想要再來問問看
因為畢竟每個人買房
他的需求會不一樣
所以就是針對像
接下來要買房子的人
他們在看預售屋
然後看成屋
協理可不可以再給我們一些的
買房的一個建議
或者是不是可以善用
像清安3.0這樣的政策
OK
我想不管是選預售屋或中古屋
其實這都沒有好壞沒有對錯
那主要關鍵在於
消費者在買房之前的
從對資金的準備
還有入住的時間
還有對屋況的接受度
以及未來能不能承擔在預售屋交屋時候的一些不確定性
那如果是想要買成屋或中古屋
目前我們建議消費者是非常好的這個進場看屋的時機
那也是尋價的一個好時機
那目前整體中古屋的房價相對是比較穩定
那甚至有一些部分供給可能比較大的區域
它價格有些小幅度的修正也比較明顯
那價格相對也比較友善
那加上現在整體市場的供給量是屬於大的
那對於有自住首購需求的買方
非常適合這個時候出來看房子
他也有足夠的時間能夠看充足的房子
再來做最後的一個決定
那如果他是想要買預售屋
那我們建議消費者就是多看多比較
雖然買預售屋確實前期的負擔
因為施工期長負擔比較輕
但是交屋之後就直接面臨到了付款
跟每個月要還貸款這件事情
大家就要精算清楚
避免交屋之後
有這個資金上面缺口的一個風險
那看屋的錢同時也要慎選
有口碑以及施工品質好的一個建商
也避免買到了爛尾樓
沒辦法交屋
或交屋的時候
整個品質不如預期
那尤其在各區
在各建案的銷售情形
決定之前不需要太沖動
還是符合多看多比價
然後再積極的溢價
爭取自己合理
以及能負擔的一個價格
那不過還是要提醒消費者
那中古屋是看得到也摸得到
它不需要等兩三年的這個施工期
然後如果對於貧宿的需求量比較高
或是重視生活機能的
不妨利用這個時間考慮
優先考慮中古屋跟成屋
會更能夠符合自身的一個需求選擇
好 謝謝協理
真的是非常實用的一個建議
那我還是要再請教協理
因為我們現在時序已經來到了第三季了
那接下來下半年
我們有沒有哪一些的關鍵因素
都要持續的來關注呢
會不會還有什麼會來影響到我們房市呢
好那目前有三個關鍵因素
要提醒觀眾朋友能夠掌握
第一個就是政策
第二個是房貸緊縮
第三個就是通膨
我們要注意在這個房市的政策
有沒有維持或是有新的政策出來
第二個銀行現在
這個有沒有錢來做這個放款的部分
第三個就是通膨是不是穩定的狀況
那這些都會影響下半年房市的一個表現
那對一般的民眾來說
其實在央行選擇性信用管制下
銀行現在是自主的風險控管
那對於房貸的審核標準還是相對的嚴格
那貸款的乘數以及利率的條件
也是相對的受限
當然能不能如期的貸款到你所需要的乘數
這個還是要事先先做一個查詢
那這也是目前在買屋的消費者
他優先要去注意的幾個點
那不過呢
央行他對於換屋主的貸款乘數
有小幅度的鬆綁
另外財政部也推出了清安3.0
可以持續的支持手購族
預估未來整體的房市
會轉趨穩定而且健康
非常謝謝賢禮
這麼多的房市的分析還有建議
我們就來總結一下今天的節目內容
在央行還沒有鬆綁信用管制之下
買方購物決策仍然是趨向保守的
因此相較於變動性高
房價又持續創新高的預售屋
成屋反而是看得到又摸得到
價格又清明瞭將近六成
所以買方在資金有限的情況之下
自然就會轉向相較於
這個市場比較友善的一個城屋
那永慶房屋也預測
2026年的第三季
城屋市場也即將呈現
量小增價頻的一個走勢
未來市場還會如何的變動
我們就要來緊盯持續的關注
政策有沒有改變
銀行有沒有前進
還有通膨會如何的來變化
Amy說的完全正確
那接下來只要消費者掌握這三大核心
就能夠精準的對應接下來的市場變化
非常感謝協力今天所帶來的
這麼精彩的趨勢分析還有數據的解讀
想掌握最精確最核心的房市資訊
一定要記得鎖定房產關鍵字
再次謝謝協力來到我們今天這裡的節目
那我們就下次見囉
謝謝協力今天的分享
拜拜